I am in mourning right now I am
incredibly upset I'm usually not
as upset but today is a tough day
um we're mourning the loss of a legend a
woman who's meant a lot to this show
someone who
has been an inspiration to me someone
who has been an inspiration to Millions
to young women and young men and people
of and young non-binary people everybody
regardless of their gender has been
impacted by this woman
um
it is a sad day in America but a very
sad day in Chicago
um because we have lost
one of the best
um an advocate
for chaos
an advocate for chaos
a woman whose reign in Chicago
came to symbolize chaos
in in the way that only a Batman villain
could like a Dick Tracy villain
like this woman presided over an
increase in crime that was just I mean
it was mind-blowing like the numbers
just kept and she was a petty vindictive
woman she went to war with limo
companies she wrote bad Yelp reviews she
was nasty to employees the first lesbian
mayor of color in Chicago
uh gotta put that in there she's a uh
and God God love her for that we
appreciate it um but this is a woman I
never thought of her as you know I never
thought of her sexuality I never thought
of even her race I thought only of what
animates her the true
um you know Spirit of Lori Lightfoot uh
is is really as a spirit of Chaos
um and let's take a look at her right
now this is her and all her glory this
is how I'll always remember her
big please
there she is
[Music]
yeah
foreign
[Music]
here she is celebrating Chicago having
the highest murder rate in the country
it's
I mean this woman
I I don't want to lose her I do not want
to lose this woman
I mean
God lover it's sad
all right well
people are listening they don't see that
they're not getting the benefit of this
visual so we'll turn this down but uh
God I mean there's no one better than
Lori Lightfoot can we go to her speech
when she left you know Lori Lyford for
those of you who don't know was the
mayor of the city of Chicago the great
City of Chicago which is descending into
a hellscape uh how many murders last
year in Chicago just out of curiosity if
we can get that Up Chicago a violent
crime there has been a major problem
there are like they were large one of my
favorite stories was like there's large
gangs of teenagers uh groups of
teenagers just running through um you
know the Midtown of Chicago the Miracle
Mile whatever you call it and they're
just robbing couples and you know you
know just creating chaos I think they're
working for Lightfoot like I think the
kids are because here's what she's got
to do now Lori now that she has been
evicted from her uh position she's been
taken out Lori now has to wage a war
against the city from the outside
because for many years she was waging a
war against the city from the inside but
now she's now from the outside has to
like make sure the city stays as crime
ridden and filthy
from the outside she's just gotta launch
attacks
coordinating attacks the year of 2021
Ended as one of the most violent on
record in Chicago a rise in the number
of shootings left more people dead than
in any single year in a quarter century
according to statistics
released by the police on Saturday
797 homicides
20 more 25 more than were recorded in
2020. it's about 800 homicides how many
a day is 365 days in a year almost like
three a day yeah there's about three
people a day in Chicago checking out
and uh you know this was also you got to
remember Lori Lightfoot went wild with
the vaccine she was threatening people
saying if you don't take the vaccine
your time has come we'll put you in jail
you know we're gonna find you again this
was the language of a of a villain this
was the language of like an all-powerful
mob boss it was not a governor here we
go
um yeah she did not [__] around when it
came to the vaccine she was like
nazi-ish she wanted everybody to get it
and if you didn't get it she did that
whole thing get up that thing where she
goes we'll put you in jail yeah that was
my favorite one where she goes we'll put
you in jail
she goes we will put you in jail and it
was just like you saw that was like the
Zenith of state power during the
pandemic when people were just coming
right out and saying if there is
anything you do that we disagree with we
are going to put you in jail and that
was like I remember people sending that
to me going like this is going to really
like be a huge problem for this woman
and it was you know people you play that
back now it seems so insane
um here it is right here
this is Lori Lightfoot
we will shut you down we will cite you
and if we need to we will arrest you and
we will take you to jail period there
should be nothing unambiguous about that
you mean nothing ambiguous treat you
like a criminal but if you act like a
criminal and you violate the law and you
refuse to do what is necessary to save
lives in the city in the middle of a
pandemic we will take you to jail get up
here get up when she did Rona Destroyer
I just this is a montage of Lori
Lightfoot I I am so sad to be losing
this woman I hope she runs for governor
I pray that Lori Lightfoot runs for
governor well before we go looks like
trick-or-treating will be happening in
Chicago this year
[Laughter]
yeah that's Chicago mayor Lori Lightfoot
coming out in full costume cape and mask
is the Rona as in Corona Destroyer
heading out Kenny to reporters and staff
at our daily news conference
trick-or-treaters will be asked to stay
in groups of six or fewer there avoid
sticking their hands into any candy
bowls and of course wear a mask with a
mask over your mouth man she's a symbol
of the pandemic isn't she Lori Lightfoot
I think now Cove is finally over
I mean I know the state of emergency was
lifted in LA but with Lori Lightfoot
leaving
it's like the state like it really is
over
this is finally done
with Lori Lightfoot
being voted out
this is sad let's look at our concession
speech here
she doesn't even seem present in her own
body
for the concession speech again so much
Mayhem
so much chaos
so bloody
this woman was the ultimate villain the
only this is the type of Mayor Chicago
should have it's one of the most corrupt
cities in the world and there's
absolutely no way it should be run by
anyone left like anyone less than a
complete utter uh crime uh boss which is
what she is
she is like you know somebody who from
uh like the Ninja Turtles would have to
invade her Lair let's see how she
conceded the election we
uh for the people of the city for years
to come I'm grateful that we work
together to remove a record number of
guns off our streets we're doing reduced
homicides and started making real
progress on Public Safety well she
didn't she didn't reduce homicide I mean
that's but who cares at this point and I
don't know what gun she's talking about
that are off the street certainly not
the 900 you know murders she didn't
really reduce any homicides but now she
can live with her wife and be happy and
like
you know just she was the mayor of
Chicago you know she'll just always
She'll always be able to tell people
like later on she'll be on some like
lesbian cruise and they'll be like what
did you do and she'll go I was the mayor
of Chicago and you go Laurie was the
mayor of Chicago she just cheated at
cards
Laurie was the mayor of Chicago because
she's corruption is the DNA of Chicago
and it runs through this woman's veins
no matter what she does any any time in
her life
she will always try to lie and this is
what I love about her so much is that no
matter what Lori life I mean she
literally just said we we we we we uh we
what about homicide she goes we decrease
homicides they were at the highest level
in 25 years but it doesn't matter she'll
always try to lie first that's what I
love about her she just it's her in you
can tell when you look at her she's
burning inside because she doesn't know
what's true anymore because there's so
much she's lied so many times
did you ever see the thing where the the
guy he just lists everything in Chicago
it's Lori Lightfoot she refuses to
answer a question and it's great you
have a guy who basically comes up and
goes here's the issue the crime's up
this is up they don't companies are
leaving Chicago nobody wants to be here
anymore and Lori Lightfoot stands there
and goes I'm just not gonna answer that
question
um you got to remember the fashion
choices too she wore these big balloon
pants she dressed up during the St
Patrick's Day Parade they were saying on
Twitter that she looked like that movie
Leprechaun in the Hood they were saying
she looked like Leprechaun in the Hood
um it was she was trolling everyone or
she wasn't
she had these weird balloon pants these
baggy like Janko jeans but they were
pants that she would wear and they like
never fit her
this is a kid who dressed up as her
but I mean I'm really gonna be sad to
see her go man
try to get that up where she refuses to
answer the question where she literally
just looks at the guy and she goes I I
disagree with your assessment entirely
and he just listed
facts about what was happening in
Chicago and she goes I just disagree
with your assessment uh entirely but I
mean it's sad man it's sad to lose her
because she became such a symbol of uh
the type of political leader that we
have
um in America now where truth is
irrelevant okay this is great Lightfoot
now screams this is this was another one
but this is also great he or she is
screaming at a reporter over a question
about crime God I love her
other right wing nuts could try to
characterize it any possible excuse me
is that appropriate yeah is that
appropriate I mean Kelly
mayor Lightfoot
the people that I speak with in Chicago
every day tell me that they're very
frustrated with your lack of a plan to
combat violent crime
[Music]
it sounds more like you support or
sympathize with the the so you you may
not have heard the admonition at the
beginning of this press conference and
frankly
hold on sir it's specific to you
ask a question and I'd be happy to
respond but if you continue to come in
here and spout a lot of nonsense and
rhetoric if that's not a question and
not acting like a journalist then I'm
not going to have any time for you
you've had a whole room of people that
you're Holding On by not asking a
question and I know you like to film me
and then you like to go on Fox News
filming you yeah so I might want to
reporter but what I want you to do is
ask a question sir don't give me your
right wing nonsense and spewing of facts
that are completely untethered from the
reality just ask the question that's all
I'm asking you ask a question so we can
move on well I'm not the only reporter
filming ask a question
right what's your question the obvious
question is simply this
there are numerous uh
violent crimes here in the city of
Chicago right last night a teenager was
shot in the head uh on our beautiful
Lake Front people around the city the
state and not only the country but
around the world I'm going to ask you to
Chicago
[Music]
a question or we're moving she's like
yeah I shot that [__]
they're like um saw a teenager was shot
Louise like on my orders I had it done
I'm the boss this is when Oswald get up
Oswald cobblepot running for mayor of
Gotham City this is when the penguin ran
Gotham City like Lori Lightfoot staring
at him he's like he goes I don't
understand you don't have a plan to
combat the crime
she's like yeah I am the criminal
I wonder if we can play this or if
YouTube's gonna like you know send
someone to our homes
it's getting so bad over there you you
can't do anything they'll send people
after you in the Street YouTube If you
play the wrong thing you're fit they'll
call and threaten your family we're
trying to stay there well anyway don't
play it it's just you get it folks if
you've seen Batman Returns
the point is that Lightfoot symbolized a
type of politician
where they didn't even try to lie uh in
a way that would make the citizenry feel
comfortable this is an important
transition It's actually an important
transition in the way things are kind of
uh crumbling uh when someone like her
basically went out warts and all
imperfect
came out and was like listen I'm kind of
a criminal so I'm not going to sit in
Judgment of other people that were
criminals
um and now listen you have many many
liars that occupy uh offices all over
the place from Congress to the governors
but there was something special about
this woman in in in my heart I like
Petty people and when she did the thing
and you could go back and listen to that
old episode where she ratted on her limo
company she literally made up that the
driver of the limo company went and used
a bathroom in her home and then the
company goes we have cameras he didn't
enter your house once she's such a
vindictive liar
even on a tiny small scale this
infinitesimal scale of trying to get a
limo driver fired
she is just such a treat
she's such an utter treat
a um you know there's something so
comforting to me about her complete like
obvious disdain for anyone who called
her out on anything anyone that would
mention a fact about Chicago the
shootings the murders the cry she hated
it she was like don't bring your
propaganda here and I love her [__]
weird voice she had like she had this
weird like breathy voice where she'd be
like listen to me if you have a question
ask a question don't bring your Fox
propaganda here don't break your
propaganda
this strange kind of like her voice box
almost didn't want to lie and she had to
like force the breath through it because
like her body was shutting down some of
the lies that she was telling and she
what did she get 16 of the vote
God Laurie it was bad it was like at
least it was bad she got trounced
17.1 who are those people just committed
criminals and I mean who were the
who are the 17.1 percent of people that
voted for Lori Lightfoot like every
measurable standard Chicago is falling
into an uh it's a hellscape and 17.1
percent of people
I mean what was their slug did life
would have a slogan
did Lori have like a slogan
everything even even her name's amazing
Lori Lightfoot just it's just the
alliteration you know Lori Lightfoot
there's just no one better
and I'm uh I'm sad to see her go you
know of all the people we [__] talk on
this show
you know there was nobody that that I
loved and had a personal affinity for
more than Lori Lightfoot she just fit I
mean the fedoras she dressed like a
gangster again like somebody like Dick
Tracy he would have to like I mean Lori
Lightfoot epitomized she looked like a
gangster she was a gangster she lied she
you know obfuscated she wouldn't answer
questions and all around her things just
totally fell apart because she was a
petty vindictive Tyrant that would go to
war with people in her Inner Circle and
she would fight these tiny small battles
instead of focusing on real things that
could actually help people and there's
no better version of a politician than
that to me it's just somebody who's like
it's all out in the open what they do
that's what made Lori Lightfoot so
special to me she was so bad at
concealing it she almost had no desire
to conceal it she just thought like
somehow it was gonna be okay you know
you've all you know seen a kid or maybe
you've been the kid who shows up to
class without homework and has no lie
nothing prepared they just go huh and
the teacher goes uh you have nothing and
they go I yeah that was Lori Lightfoot
no dog ate my homework no oh I left it
in the car no it it was 100
I don't have it and I don't remember you
even uh asking it uh asking me to do it
and I don't know what your problem is
and I'm just gonna stare at you from my
seat until you give up